[Music]
in prison escape news Oh submitted by hi
my name is Grace
I bet you it's a Korean girl yeah
it's such a common name sir Esther yeah
okay a notorious French gangster serving
a 25-year sentence made a dramatic
helicopter escape from prison I think I
really heard about this one yeah you
heard about it I heard about our button
that's an El Chapo's why do European
thugs always do [ __ ] so double-oh-seven
style
that's classy right he didn't go through
[ __ ] tunnel no I mean that can't cross
there's some [ __ ] helicopter escape for
sick but hanging off a rope ladder like
a rope like the helicopter just flying
away jizz like they can I hope he's
talking [ __ ] too yeah he's like I'll see
you in the next one that's my
transatlantic that's my criminal the
criminal you call you're stuck in the
1920's 1930's by my movies exactly yeah
so this gangster who is French and
Algerian he his name is ray don't fight
fade oh babe
his name is radon Peggy this will puts
makeup on his head I can't [ __ ]
makeup from here always
prisoner does look like a cool-ass this
is like a cool-ass village there's like
a cool doctor Eva he's been in a [ __ ]
cartoon I know he has why does he gotta
look like a villain though like straight
up cuz he isn't because we already know
he's a villain he looks like that dude
was that actor on Titanic who's the
villain
Billy's act like Billy's name give me a
good so this guy donated 1.5 million
dollars for charity in Africa he fits
the bill he does he fits ability to take
care of sick cats and poker like a world
poker player yeah there you go I'll say
poker villains always do that they have
the one side they donate to budget the
other side they're trying to kill
Superman you know it's like this man set
the world record for jerking off in an
hour it's like now the most successful
car set car dealership in Simi Valley
there you go it's like just put in the
bed on an NFL team yeah yeah yeah are
the get your next house no II would real
estate agent I'm gonna do does it get
like he's a gangster right yeah the
French gangster yeah I don't sure it
looks like no crayon with the face he's
missing a few chromosomes that's what's
happening here so don't take him
seriously cuz you know it's France you
know they just steal like the criminals
they're their jewel thieves Oh sexy
jewel thieves oh yeah he actually wrote
a book distills ruby ruby he's classy
back in 2009 he wrote a book outlining
his his childhood growing up in the
streets of Paris and how that's
autobiography how that led him into a
life of professional
crime dad that will grew up on the
streets of Paris doing that [ __ ] cup
trick when you put the ball in and
you're like which one do you get I can't
imagine the cover-up the criminal story
like now vo that that's why how he
started
some blame is eruption the clean streets
of Paris this is a young boy I like this
clean Paris is good bro
there's a bird's in Paris bro yeah but
I'm trying to intentionally doesn't turn
into movie oh very clean set always yeah
even the ghettos really clean we'll see
what happens from now from here on out
there to catch him again if he's gonna
do one of the guys actually second
prison break whoa
the first one he like his wife went to
go visit him and inside of some tissue
boxes there was like explosives and he
he just walked out of the [ __ ] prison
just exploding walls after wall holy
[ __ ] this guy's tight he's like [ __ ]
Batman is that [ __ ] badass
he's [ __ ] Batman one of those true
villains let you see in a movie [ __ ]
yeah he just blast his way through five
prison doors while holding guards
hostage as human shield
holy Shh that's like an x-men villain
dude yeah dude I feel like if you escape
like if you get away with like that like
they should just be like you know what
yeah like just get rid of the set go to
Antarctica base okay so let me show you
guys a video clip of when he this is the
prison where he was staying in Paris
sexy landed in the courtyard somewhere
over here
that's a crooked ass Pentagon he had
four or five people of his loyal friends
help him escape did he go to leave -
yeah so they went with him and then they
ended up getting into a van and then
from there they don't know where they
went because both the helicopter and the
van that shadows all the homies those
unlike those the homies like you know
the helicopter looks like it was made
out of PVC pipes that would be more
impressive if you'd escaped helicopter
turn a second if you made that [ __ ]
laughter but I sound devices for Spanish
sprint I heard it's the way prisoner has
an iPhone and is so crazy ones the part
where he's hanging on the ladder and
[ __ ] no matters
oh we're not like yeah no I'm into [ __ ]
get shot up yeah oh I see they would do
that that cellmate only has an iPhone 3
I wish he had a better quality he's this
is this guy like the El Chapo of France
yeah I don't know he must be he has a
sort of connected that's what yeah is
there any info on what type of crimes he
does uh robbery and extortion that's
disappointing what you want drugs
diamond smuggling yeah I wanted some
kind of like million dollar heist made
fast like died bank that developer yeah
like some kind of cuz you know a lot of
these guys robberies in the movies
they're like whenever they get visited
and in prison and [ __ ] there's like a
special guy and they always have like a
special thing like like they're like an
international criminal that knows how to
like make diseases or like they know how
to [ __ ] make yeah he's building the
rocket to destroy the world
yeah for profit yeah so he's just stole
a bet back yet and [ __ ] like what so the
way he was able to get the helicopters
like his friends that helped him escape
they went to get like first time flying
lesson and they're saying like they were
like father and son and that weren't
they went and the instructor told them
because apparently they picked out the
specific helicopter that they wanted and
the instructor was like no that's not
for first-time users or whatever and so
they ended up just pulling out a gun and
held him at gunpoint
oh you're gonna [ __ ] fly this
helicopter right over this prison that's
how I got involved so that was crazy
oh and then also he is like a huge fan
of Pokemon
the film I love he that's why my
family's even approached Michael Mann
who is a director and he told him at
like a Paris Film Festival once and told
them you were my technical adviser and
he studies Hollywood heist movies oh wow
for his icicle bands no joke
cuz Michael Mann learns everything about
what he's writing about but like when he
cuz he's a writer director so like when
he did this movie called thief he had
James Caan like using an actual like
blowtorch think to actually drill into a
safe they had James Caan the actor
actually do that wish take the time to
to drilled the safe himself and they all
just filmed everything like it was
[ __ ] Michael Mann is no joke I met
Michael Mann he's I went to a screening
of that movie in he's [ __ ] dope that
he's the man yeah heats incredible to if
you haven't seen he you owe it to
yourself oh my god yeah are you a huge
fan of that movie I feel like dark night
the the beginning sequence by
Christopher Nolan was inspired by he
told us it feels like so some do feel
like does his research on real heists
and talks to ex-cons and whatever and
then he writes his movies and then this
guy gets inspired by like true events
yeah I'm so like I'm curious what he's
doing now this dude he's just like
watching The Italian Job
just watch the ocean ocean's 13 watching
ocean's [ __ ] 13 and [ __ ] with Sandra
Bullock and he's like we could do this
like that kind he's probably watching
ocean's 8 now I'm Rihanna oh that's true
so now he's gonna get all of this him
and his homegirls he's gonna get a sex
change home gross yeah so she's eight
now it's all girls school a DS right so
now they're gonna infiltrate the fashion
industry or whatever I'm always
surprised how there isn't more like
women
heists like these stories you know we
just never get caught
okay that's a good point yeah now there
was that one what was that from the girl
that white girl who supposedly got like
kidnapped back in the day the Patty
Hearst of course yeah the Patty Hearst
story
look how are you looking at me because
I'm a little white guy you know the
story of whitey pedia all right but you
knew though I did y'all would know it's
her sounds familiar I just don't know
what millionaire daughter of God like
kidnapped and they did a and the people
kidnapped her they did a like heist
together like a bank heist together and
she was all in it like supposedly they
say oh [ __ ] welcome to it yeah she was
all into it like oh she got like
supposedly really like brainwashed to do
it with us oh I heard about it dude it's
like the the robberies in the Hollywood
Hills where they ripped off Orlando
Bloom those all chicks was it all not
all chicks but it was like chick
Orchestra tell me about it I'm like
Alexis Neiers
the the so I watch there's this [ __ ]
hilarious show on Netflix was a reality
show called pretty wild and I thought it
was great it was like a shitty reality
show starring the like one of the girls
who was one of the main people who
ripped off all these homeless and
parasites oltenia okay Amanda bloom all
of that movie with the girl problem of
Harry Potter was in it - yes yeah yeah
but that was like a female like like
crime earning is pretty funny story life
no they really did it it was true story
did multiple Hollywood houses and they
came up with like hundreds of thousands
of dollars worth of you there's like
stories of individual ladies to that
that steal like really expensive jewelry
there's this one lady I think she just
grew up in a really shitty home in
Detroit and she started stealing I went
to all black all back lady yeah yeah she
got caught recently right yeah but she's
been to Europe and all these other
places and they need to make a movie
about her I've read that a story yeah
but she would go in and pretend like
she's a famous actress or like a some
type of princess or whatever and she'll
be like let me see that diamond let me
see this whatever and every one of them
just walk out that's ballsy so this
French gangster do now the
saying that he might be disguising
himself as an Orthodox Jew to evade
authorities because he does that's a
good that's all around oh I get that one
disguise the disguise is just anywhere
you can buy that anywhere really he
speaks Hebrew and he wrote in his 2010
biography about how dressing like a very
religious Jew is the perfect way to
evade point why would he do this in a
biography and publish it or at least why
wouldn't if he knew he published it why
would he just follow through with it
that's well that's uh that's just a
theory that he might be doing that
because he's doing the opposite of that
now yeah now he's a Filipino make sense
yeah or like maybe that's too obvious
they'll be like oh you would never do
the actually actual thing that he wrote
about and it might be the perfect those
guys now he's beaches why don't people
do that I would just like if you're
known like this right like go to like a
KISS concert wearing makeup like go be a
Juggalo like ICP fan or so yeah like
like you can be disguised at all times
it's a guy's a [ __ ] drug like this
guys would be not wearing a beanie just
one day this one's gonna not wear it it
has walk around with perfect Dover hair
you gotta shave your facial hair to wear
button-up shirt maybe that's gonna suck
the one day I won't have to go in the
sky that can wear my beanies we have
facial hair
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]